les problèmes d'argent non un groupe
croyez-moi ça peut vous ruiner des
histoires ça c'est dit ça peut vous
ruiner des histoires moi je me suis fait
avoir sur un sur un lustre un lustre et
un lustre
d'accord je peux vous dire que l'ust m'a
fait mal aux fesses 1 à west à dire
barils et est énorme
on vous l'avait obligé à l'âge à payer
très cher je peux pas dire aller qu'on
ne fait pas on appris du mariage d'arrêt
à cause d'un lustre
non mais ça ça n'a pas arrangé les
choses croyait alors qu'est la raison de
plus absurde pour lequel vous avez
quitté quelqu'un a par exemple vous
admire
pourquoi sa démesure
je ne sais pas j'ai les villages les
déraisons véhicule c'est quand on est à
ces jeunes en général est très amoureuse
d'un garçon et puis un jour hélas va à
la chasse aux oeufs ou c'est le petit
gars dans la logorrhée deuil et qu'il
avait au moins 15 ans et s'est pas passé
à la crotte de nez est cassé la croûte
de la crotte de nez ça passe pas bah
ouais ouais ouais
daniel moreau banon déjà en avoir moi
parce qu'il voulait pas que je chante il
avait raison
aurélien de l'as tu es méchant et donc
il vous aussi vous acquittez moi il me
disait si tu veux chanter va chanter
dans la salle de bains qui tu que tu
m'emmerdes comme je disais non je veux
briller en deux
je veux aller chanter à la télé je veux
faire la star ac et vous voyez la grande
carrière
merci possède pour cette belle anecdote
alors maxime je n'ai jamais quitté
personnes
donc ça m'a embêté en jaune et
benjamines alors profitez-en pour vous
acquitter
non parce que ma copine de l'époque est
tombée amoureuse d'un rockeur aller vers
le quoi et barclays la plus grosse
défaite pour un point conjointe anne un
conjoint un ipad à ramallah territoire d
une tablette et ça fait cinq ans et
toujours pas compris qu'on sait la
marque s'appelle aubaine
centea et vous avez vous vraiment soit
vous êtes vraiment comme ça soit vous le
faites exprès c'est encore plus grave et
moi alors j'ai vraiment je vous je vous
et allez y vous aussi parce que la la la
la le la brochette à alès la prochaine
la prochaine des prix nobel je voudrais
pas là mais le niveau est faible mais
voilà vigiles annoncé quitter quelqu'un
non là c'est une parure très jolie que
j'avais acheté pour fatou est alors
voilà pour fatou donc d'ailleurs fatou
je pense pas tout je pense donc deux
mariages fondés ou gmail position vous
faire à vous occuper de vos divorce et
moi de mon mariage
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas très gentil mais bon d'abord
je n'ai divorce et que 3 des français
entre connexes de divorce
des figurines mariage vous de wi2wi mais
deux fois il de même
ouais ouais 90-94 un roi c'est beau un
certain johnny h comptera pas déjà passé